the first trailer for the Twilight Zone
2019 remake has just dropped and whilst
there flies by in less than 90 seconds
there's still a lot to unpack from it
The Twilight Zone is a show that I
absolutely adored growing up and in my
college years I spent hours upon hours
watching the episodes my favorite ever
one was called the howling man and it's
centered around a man stumbling across a
secret cult during a storm that believed
they managed to capture the devil and
lock him up as a prisoner the man
eventually discovers him and he sees
he's just a frail polite young man and
during the episode he tries to convince
him to say I'm free I don't want to
spoil the ending but it has an
incredible twist and whilst that episode
itself doesn't appear to be getting
remade there are actually three in the
trailer that appear to be from the
original series throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about those episodes as
well as giving my thoughts on the series
as a whole there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything in regards to the show then I
highly suggest that you turn off now for
everyone else don't adjust your YouTube
channel just sit back relax and enjoy my
breakdown of the twilight zone trailer
okay the first major episode that we can
definitely confirm is a remake of
Nightmare at 20,000 feet this classic
episode followed William Shatner on a
plane as he was slowly driven insane by
a monster that appeared to be destroying
the fuselage from the outside Shatner is
the only one that can apparently see it
and the episode centers around him
trying to convince the other passengers
that he's not crazy the episode has been
parodied by Ace Ventura The Simpsons and
even Johnny Bravo it's definitely the
show signature episode and even got
remade in the Twilight Zone film in 1983
the floating head that we see at the
beginning of the new trailer is the same
as the monsters and it definitely
appears that the episode we'll follow is
similar tale where it differs is that we
see the main protagonists off the plane
and by a lake it appears that his
journey will continue beyond the plane
as in the original
episode it was restricted to this the
episode ended with Shatner being
escorted away but the camera lingered on
the plane's engine long enough to show
that it had been damaged
whether Jordan peeler will take this
route isn't clear but it's certainly an
interesting take the second episode that
appears to be a remake is the one where
it's clear that a child is running for
president whilst it's not a direct
adaptation this seems to be sticking
pretty closely to the episode titled
it's a good life in that a young boy
possesses incredible almost godlike
mental powers and he's able to read and
control Minds this pretty much puts
everyone at his mercy and all those who
offend him are killed in the episode the
boy named Anthony isolates his town from
the rest of the world and rules it as a
tyrant
however just being a young boy he has
absolutely no idea how to run industry
agriculture and so on thus the town
slowly starts to die and crumble in on
itself however everyone is so terrified
of Anthony that they pretend like
everything is going amazingly the acting
is fantastic and throughout all of the
adults kind of smile through gritted
teeth in its modern adaptation I can
imagine this being a very clear Trump
metaphor with the president being
portrayed as a spoiled brat which is
something that those opposite Trump
often call him it's definitely an
interesting take and is something that
cements just how necessary that the
twilight zone is in today's climate the
third episode is called in the nick of
time and this centers around the devil
head machine that we see in the trailer
in the original work this was a
fortune-telling device a couple begin to
test it and slowly realize that it's
very very accurate they eventually are
led to believe that it's unsafe to leave
the diner that they're occupying at 3:00
p.m. and one of the characters becomes
obsessed with this notion it's basically
about how there's no future but what we
make for ourselves and that worry will
forever hold us back
it's a neat one to remake as it's
definitely one of the more niche
episodes but I can't wait to see how it
plays out I can't wait to see what the
other episodes offer I would have liked
to a focus on them but I'm not too sure
exactly what plot route they will take
and it would have just purely been
speculation whereas these episodes I
feel they're definitely gonna go this
way
if you want to know more about those
episodes then make sure you stay tuned
to the channel for full breakdowns on
them upon their release on the CBS
streaming service on April 1st
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer and if there's anything
that I missed comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and check out my
breakdown of the haunting of Bligh Manor
trailer which will be linked at the end
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]